you got to hand it to Republicans when
they find a scapegoat they will use that
scapegoat for everything and for
congressman Patrick Mian who's a
Pennsylvania Republican Obamacare even
forced him to sexually harass one of his
staffers what'd ya mean became sort of
obsessed with a young former aide that
worked for him and I guess she at some
point started a relationship with
someone outside of me ins office like
what we would call a normal relationship
with someone that was age-appropriate
for her and me and became sort of
curious and then he became jealous and
then he became hostile and it ultimately
pushed this staffer to start working
remotely and eventually she quit and
mian initially denied that he did
anything wrong he eventually ended up
settling with the staffer using taxpayer
dollars when she filed a formal
complaint and then recently he talked
about the situation with the
Philadelphia Inquirer and he said he
developed feelings towards the staffer
that at one point he saw her as his soul
mate that's his quote not mine that he
was selfish when he found out that she
had started this relationship that
they'd sometimes share ice cream after
work and he would express his romantic
feelings for her and that he would
sometimes hold hugs with her maybe a
little bit longer than was appropriate
it all sounds pretty damn pathetic to be
totally honest with you but he says he
didn't actually sexually harass her and
then this is the gold he said that he
was hostile to her in the first place
because of all the pressure he was under
from his constituents because of
Obamacare that's right
constituents were all over him because
of Obamacare and this just got to him so
much that he started mistreating a
staffer which is what led to this entire
fiasco you know when you put it that way
hard to blame the guy for anything right
I mean really it's Obama's fault or even
starting the process of creating
Obamacare the party of personal
responsibility seems to have no qualms
whatsoever finding other people and
things to blame for what are very
clearly personal decision
and of course this isn't the only
hypocrisy because Mian was also involved
in the House Ethics Committee and he was
helping to review claims of sexual
harassment against other members of
Congress and Paul Ryan immediately
removed me and from the House Ethics
panel in light of these revelations and
an investigation has started into his
behavior it seems almost like a fake
story right yeah you know that meme
thanks Obama yeah we have a new one
thanks Obamacare saying thanks Obamacare
of responsible for anything apparently
that Pat Mia never did because he was
under so much pressure you can vote this
guy out right he is up for re-election
in the fall as are all members of
Congress he actually is opposed some of
these seats run either unopposed or
effectively unopposed where there's like
some no money challenger from the
opposition party that's never never
going to have a shot mian is actually
expected to have a bit of a tough time
in the 2018 election so I say vote him
out right away because you know what I
support personal responsibility and if
he can't even behave himself with his
staff because of the pressure on him
because of Obamacare doesn't sound very
responsible to me yeah and he can't take
the heat apparently I mean I had the
opportunity now to vote for someone
who's going to protect the Affordable
Care Act right not like this guy no this
guy wants it out and just totally
strikes me is just a horrible person to
do this and I I don't I don't buy into
big picture like oh this is a good
person and this is a bad person people
in different circumstances are capable
of good and bad and concerning and and
benevolent actions and circumstance
plays a big role but this just doesn't
sound like someone I would ever want
anything to do with yeah when the report
says that he would share ice cream with
the staffer that's amazing wonder was it
the same ice cream because that would be
very troubling I don't think so I think
they each got he would get a soy-based
ice cream like product and the staffer
was into coconut cream yeah so it was
both both uh both dairy-free but let's
go to not exactly of the same kind I've
no idea what what kind of ice cream they
had but hope it was pistachio